mich hat tatsächlich auch ein thema
massiv belastet und zwar das thema
digitale gewalt es geht darum dass
digitale gewalt immer so surreal klingt
aber sie ist genau das gegenteil sie ist
nämlich real und auch wenn es im netz
stattfindet haben wir auch mittlerweile
im netz kommunikation wir treffen uns
wir haben wir treffen uns zum glas wein
wir essen zusammen wir reden wir haben
diverse räume und trotz allem findet
leider genau da diese gewalt statt wir
reden von
cyber-mobbing wir reden von stalking
gerät von section wir reden aber eben
auch von der leider sehr oft gehört hate
speech der sogenannten hass rede die von
rechts von links und von ganz vielen
menschen leider kommen von 99 fällen von
100 fällen wird nur eine angezeigte sind
99 zu wenig und ich habe letztens ein
junges mädchen kennenlernen dürfen da
wurde von ihr als sie 15 jahre alt war
leider vom ex freund ein video
hochgeladen wie sie beim sex gefilmt
wurde dieses mädchen hat die schule
abgebrochen egal wo sie hinkommt sie
wird immer wieder damit konfrontiert es
ist ihre familie leidet darunter sie
selber ist für ihr leben gekennzeichnet
und vor allem auch was die hassrede
angeht ich selber hab es leider oft
genug erleben müssen ich sage ehrlich
ist demotiviert es macht meine vision
kaputt das macht meine ideen kaputt und
viele menschen haben keine lust mehr in
die politik einzusteigen keine lust mehr
ihre vision festzuhalten weil diese
hassrede einfach nur eins macht alles
also das sitzt man da und kriegt
sozusagen gänsehaut weil jedes wort
natürlich war es und ich glaube wir
müssen über unsere mittel nachdenken mit
denen wir sozusagen dagegen zu felde
ziehen wollen denn die scheinen
limitiert zu sein wenn ich das richtig
sehe passiert das alles ja vor aller
augen und der staat verfolgungsbehörden
die in der analogen welt sofort tätig
werden sind in der digitalen welt
ausgebremst aus verschiedenen gründen
datenschutz
server in anderen ländern auf die sie
keinen zugriff haben irgendwelche
genehmigungen gerichtsurteile also ich
finde die eigentliche herausforderung
ist neben dem trost der den opfern
gegenüber und den arm nehmen der opfer
und hilfe der opfer diese leichte
perversion dass die freiheiten die uns
der rechtsstaat einräumt und die
schutzmechanismen die der rechtsstaat
dem individuum einräumt der staat darf
nicht in meine daten schauen und der
staat darf nicht in meine kommunikation
schaut der staat darf muss mich in ruhe
lassen in meiner wohnung das genau das
sozusagen diese straftaten und das ist
ja nichts anderes diese straftaten
ermöglicht das finde ich eine
beunruhigende eigentlich ganzen abend
hat die beunruhigung erkenntnis dieses
amt wie man das auf knackt man muss ja
eigentlich sagen im netz muss gelten was
auch außerhalb des netzes gilt das sagen
auch alle immer schon aufgehört das von
politikern ihrer partei von allen
möglichen politikern dann bedeutet das
aber nicht das gleiche sondern es viel
komplizierter sind viel weniger
einsatzkräfte unterwegs ist sind immer
irgendwelche sonderkommissionen mit 20
leuten statt 2000 leute so dass das
finde ich ist die große herausforderung
der jetztzeit was ich tatsächlich
problematisch finde an dieser ganzen
digitalen gewalt ist das werden anderes
bewusstsein haben weil es ja eben nur
digital ist dann sagt man immer ach so
schlimm ist es ja nicht und es ist ja
nur digital und sie hat mir noch nichts
angetan gerade frauen passiert das oft
und man sagt ach wie so wenn er mich
sorgt ich hab den ja gar nicht gesehen
aber genau das ist das schlimme man weiß
nicht wo der nebenan ist es einer aus
dem umfeld ich weiß es nicht und es
schürt ängste die sogar zu selbstmord
führen
man muss einmal vielleicht noch sagen es
passiert ja fast nichts was es nicht in
der analogen welt auch gibt nur es
passiert in deckung und meer und an und
ist zu den anonymen brief mit
bedrohungen und sogar im ausland aber
hat einen und nicht 1000 oder 1
millionen ich würde eine vielleicht
unterscheidung machen wollen ich finde
zwischen hassrede und den sexualdelikten
diesen gibt es für mich noch so eine so
eine trennung ich finde auch nicht dass
das eine der anfang vom anderen ist und
ich würde fast sogar sagen nicht milde
aber weniger härte bei der hassrede
dafür mehr und ultimative hatte bei den
sexualdelikten ich zum beispiel binde
auch häufiger sagen wir mal von menschen
die jetzt meine meinungsbeiträge oder
mich selber oder meine frisur oder meine
fränkische herkunft wird als anhang was
nicht so doll finden um zum beispiel mal
zu sagen
angegriffen und ich merke aber dass das
an mit mir als erwachsenen nichts macht
sondern es sagt bei mir eher dafür dass
ich ergründen will warum derjenige so
wütend auf mich ist und ganz oft wenn
ich dann in eine diskussion eintreten
die sie bei von denen manche sagen das
darfst du gar nicht also solchen leuten
antwortet man gar nicht so will ich doch
gar nicht antwort mache ich aber
manchmal und manchmal stelle ich fest
ich will jetzt nicht romantisch klingen
aber manch und kann es auch nicht
quantifizieren aber manchmal ständig
fest dass jemand nur nicht anders mit
seiner wut und einer fehlenden rhetorik
umgehen konnte eigentlich aber von etwas
angetrieben war was für mich interessant
ist zur kenntnis zu nehmen also dass ich
drehe jetzt sozusagen zu einem kern vor
weil ich den hut wegschubsen der
eigentlich interessant ist das gibt es
bestimmt auch das gleiche argument kann
man nur bei sexualdelikten in keiner
weise ins feld
wenn er hat sich in der 2 ich bring dich
um und so was das ist nicht mehr hast
das ist schon ein stück
natürlich habt viele ich meine ich
polarisiere natürlich sehr stark aber
ich habe viele hater und rolle die dann
irgendwie auf instagram twitter
natürlich unter dem pseudonym anonymen
dann ganz lautstark gegen mich hetzen
diskreditieren aber das fehlen meistens
die gegenargumente meistens projiziert
man irgendwas vielleicht auch
minderwertigkeitskomplexe oder stress
mit freundin oder frau dahingehend
sollte man da auf jeden fall schon die
politik aktiv werden dass man in zukunft
mit klarnamen vielleicht aktiviert wird
und twitter facebook und wie sie alle
heißen die schützen die ja auch noch da
kommt mir gar nicht dran teilweise und
das mobbing ist ganz ganz schlimm vor
allem auch bei jugendlichen weil die
noch nicht so reif sind wie ein
erwachsener und damit auch nicht umgehen
können wenn die dann an und gemobbt
werde nach dem motto hey ich habe ein
bild von dir oder irgendwas das gibt ja
frauen aber auch medienkompetenz beiden
jungen menschen hinzu kommt dass man
einfach weil ich mache kein video mit
einem freund waren drei wochen ist das
sowieso weg nach oder machen die
nacktfotos und schickt die rum und so
weiter es kann überall an allen schulen
gang und gäbe und dann müssen wir
anfangen den jugendlichen zu sagen die
schon mit drei vier fünf jahren mit
rumrennen zu sagen hey ihr braucht
medienkompetenz macht keine fotos von
euch stellt die nicht online die kann es
kann alles gegen mich verwendet werden
heute sagt er vielleicht die besten
freunde aber morgen ist sie oder er
bekommt gerade ein gedanke ich war gehen
auszusprechen obwohl er wahrscheinlich
falsch und dumm und
verurteilenswert ist kann es nicht auch
sein dass insbesondere die junge
generation durch die inflation des
mobbings quasi eine art
abwehrmechanismus
sich kreiert und aufbaut also dass jetzt
das mobbing meiner tochter gegenüber
wegen irgendwelcher keine ahnung ärgern
ist in der schule oder sonst irgendwas
oder in den beschriebenen sinne auf
meine tochter gar nicht mehr so wirkt
wie es auf uns wirkt die wir nicht so
sozialisiert sind sondern dass die
sicherheit denkt dass sie die nacktfotos
rum also dass das quasi so eine art
evolution des umgangs damit ist das soll
den distrikt nicht relativieren aber es
löst bei mir schon so ein bisschen aus
menschen reagieren ja auf alles wir sind
wir alle in einem emotions prozess dass
irgendwann die inflation also beim 1000
verschickten mobbing nacktfoto denkt man
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr psychologisch
ist so schrecklich leid der jugendlichen
ist ja nicht besser geworden den letzten
jahrzehnten das weiß auch nicht sie sind
ja schon ganz anders sozialisiert sie
sind ja schon mit tik tok und mit
sexualisierten videos in musikclips und
mit allem möglichen mit mit mit rap
gangsta rap texten werden sie
konfrontiert sobald sie englisch können
und die rap wirklich üblich und da ein
frauenbild das man kotzen könnte also
das bedeutet ja und aber das werden ja
keine dummen demütigung sich unterwerfen
denn junge frauen sondern die die wissen
das ist das in der welt gehabt bevor wir
das jetzt und gut also ich würde das
nicht gut reden oder po sich neben
seinen versuchen du weißt und sozusagen
soeben vom alter her zu brechen ich weiß
wie ich fand von von frau wischhusen den
gedanken auch sehr gut mit ihnen auch
mit dem klarnamen und dass man was
dagegen machen soll es gibt kleine ja
auch die ansicht dass facebook und co ja
auch vom haßleben weil hans schweickardt
und wird geteilt und dass wir es
brauchen also klarnamen für die zukunft
ja also ich finde auch dass die eine
ganz andere policy brauchen sondern
gerade diese firmen müssen sich dazu
bekennen dass sie ganz klar dagegen
vorgehen wir brauchen bin ich auch bei
claus strunz weil den behörden komplett
eigene abteilung die sich darum kümmern
und dass es dass man anonym anzeige
erstatten kann weil nichts ist schlimmer
als wenn es im sande verläuft und
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir darüber
sprechen dass es rauskommt dass es
publik wird und damit wir eben nicht
hornhaut auf der seele geregelt das ist
vielleicht überhaupt sei es wichtig sie
dafür ständig in gesprächen das fechten
erwischt das thema aufgegriffen
[Musik]